okay I thought those quickly turning
from a BuzzFeed video into my just
personal diary I think it's [ __ ] do
you think I'm prettier or something or
anything has changed about the way you
feel about me pheromones are chemical
messengers produced by the body like
sweat or oil that elicit a behavioral or
physiological response from other
organisms and it's thought that they
might play a role in human attraction so
we decided to buy some online and ship
them to the office this week we're gonna
be trying to pheromones to see if we can
attract people so that should be
interesting
I'm interested in trying pheromones
because I'm still looking for a husband
I am single and I'm looking for
something more regular I'm curious to
see if like my husband likes me a little
more if I get like a random text of like
K grow you up or something like that I
am a self-proclaimed tinder Queen but in
person I just sort of like turn into a
little clamshell I mean might as well
try give me a little boost of confidence
no it smells like middle school locker
room so I'm gonna put some on right now
I'm gonna vlog this week to see how
people treat me differently or maybe not
if anyone gives me prolonged eye contact
or flirts with me or like gives me sort
of like heart eye emoji vibes and
because I need to know stay one I'm
wearing pheromones and I'm very excited
so we'll see if it's actually gonna do
anything how people come up to me
you have people smell me and people want
to try and kiss me that's what I think
it's gonna happen okay so I did three
experiments one was to see if a cute guy
at a coffee shop that I kind of make
eyes with sometimes was gonna notice me
so specifically with this coffee store
guy I feel like we have a flirtation
maybe I'm making that up
not quite sure definitely want cussed
out the stuff today we'll see so I just
got home to see if Paul things are more
attractive do you find me more
attractive today of course
so I guess it's not working yet update
he was there and he went out of his way
to say hi to me but then he called me
buddy don't know what that means don't
want to be called buddy ever I went to
dinner last night with a gal pal and it
honestly made me a little uncomfortable
how well it was received by her my one
friend grabbed my hand and spent a
little bit of time with it I think maybe
if I were straight man that could be
seen as like a success I am officially
ready to go out on the town and I will
be putting it on probably does think Ola
on it to see if anyone at the bar tries
to talk to me no one talked to me a guy
was sitting literally next to me playing
an iPhone game instead of talking to me
it's day three of wearing the pheromones
and I think it's [ __ ] I have not had
anyone come up to me being like oh my
god you smell sexy and amazing I want to
have sex with you maybe that's not what
it's supposed to be for I don't know
last night was a total bust
uh no one hit on us I'm beginning to
lose hope for this stuff we were cooking
dinner together and I really wanted the
avocado so I'm gonna try to convince him
to go out and get some I don't think he
wants to go it but I want to put some
pheromones and try to work my charm I'm
going to grab a quick workout see if I
can capture a couple boys he's gonna go
get me an avocado because I want it one
and he's juicy not this nice I'm just
leaving the gym and one of the coaches
who's a female actually asked if
something was different and they've both
been girls so maybe it's working just
maybe not specifically for my personal
objectives I'm officially going on a
date so we're gonna see if this works
for science it is day 5 of this
pheromones experiment and nothing has
happened I just reek of like man cologne
if anything I feel like fewer people are
noticing me I forgot to check back in
after my date last night and it was
great I don't know if it was my smell in
fact I specifically asked if my smell
had anything to do with like chemistry
or whatever and he said you smell nice
so I'll take it you don't love me a
little more
and of course an email because every day
that we move that's a life did attract
some female attention not my preference
straight men go run and tell my week
with the pheromones was my week as
normal no one came up to me on the
street no one was dying to go out with
me no one hit on me at the gym and it's
happened before without the pheromones
so nothing incredible that people like
off the street were like gosh like come
here which I was hoping for I'm gonna
say that my results were inconclusive
the coffee shop he did notice me but he
called me buddy it to going hook to the
bar no one came up and talked to me
third one was the tinder date which I so
I don't think this pheromones actually
worked I don't think you need to put
like essential oil to lower you to be
like attractive to other people if
you're around people that make you feel
good that radiates and people are like
wow make one person smile and an entire
room smile that's how you are beautiful
and that's what makes you awesome and
that's honestly what keeps the men
flocking also alternative theory this
ginormous blue coat just gives me a lot
of attention who knows
[Music]